Learner B1: هل هو اللوف.
Learner B3: كل شباب عاملين
Learner B1: منذ.
Learner B3: أخبار الأسبوع معكو هل ابتديتوا بعد النهارده بس يعني ابتديتوا.
Learner B4: يا مريم، كيف الحال؟
Learner B3: إزاي كندا عاملة
Learner B4: الحمد لله عليكم يا شباب بعد الزلزال ده مبارح كله تمام.
Learner B3: مكنش ضعيف يعني انتو كنتوا صاحيين ولا.
Learner B4: أنا كنت صاحية. وكنت قاعدة بعمل حاجات على اللابتوب وبعدين لقيت الكنبة انقعد على اللت يمشي.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B3: الإيه بتمشي.
Learner B4: الكنبة بتمشي بتمشي.
Learner B3: يعني.
Learner B1: ليه معرض.
Learner B4: تراجع فده يخاف بس مش كله الجوع ده برضه غريب.
Learner B3: إمم.
Learner B4: بعدين
Learner B4: قلت يا جماعة ما في حد حسني حاسة بيه أختي قالت لي والله أنا ساعتها حاسة إني أنا دايخة وبتقلب.
Learner B4: بس قلت يمكن أنا جعانة.
Learner B1: هم كلنا كنا دايخين أنا كذا حديخ إمم.
Learner B3: برضه.
Learner B4: على حسب أوكي.
Learner B3: كنت بتقولي مبارح كان عندك حريقة جنبك حاجة كده.
Learner B4: أنا عندي عندي أوف موتير اللي أنا فيها
Learner B4: إنت منين أصلا يا علي.
Learner B3: أنا قاهر.
Learner B4: كيم فكر.
Learner B3: عند الأهرامات كده في الرماية يعني.
Learner B4: في الرماية. آلات حداء الأهرام.
Learner B3: إذا أنت قريب مني أوي.
Learner B4: ، كان في اسمه مكان اسمه بتاع الكهرباء ده عندنا بيحفروا بيعملوا مسجد وغالبا حد أعمل حاجات.
Learner B3: شهر أو حاجة.
Learner B4: لا لا ما فيش أي حاجة الحمد لله
Learner B4: فهم كانوا العمرية في نفس الوقت.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: أنا كنت نايم وكان والسرير يعني السرير يتحرك إن في فور تحت السرير ودي حاجة ابشع من
Learner B1: فمستاني حد يأكد لي المعلومة إن ده مش فار وإن دي زلزال عادي.
Learner B4: في.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B4: فرج يصير.
Learner B1: أنا متوحش مش فرع عادي لا فرن متوحش إن في فرن يرج السرير اللي بيحصل
Learner B1: يلا الحمد لله أنظر ولطيف
Learner B1: حد ارد باسك.
Learner B4: الحمد لله.
Learner B3: أنا بدأت.
Learner B4: ما.
Learner B3: نعم.
Learner B1: الطوف كان بجد الطوف كان.
Learner B4: ثانية وحدة خليني أطبخ وبس جي تي ام
Learner B1: أوه.
Learner B4: قوي.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B7: أنا قرأت إم دة تخديت.
Learner B1: هو فعلا
Learner B4: هو تقريبا انت بتلملم وراقك كلو يعني أنت.
Learner B1: ألملم ورائي يعني في إيه ليه كده
Learner B4: من الممكن.
Learner B1: كملي كملي.
Learner B4: أنا مش عارفة لو صحتي إن شاء الله.
Learner B3: أنا بس كنت بقول آخر كم يوم يعني كنت بتقولي إيه.
Learner B4: منلم بنلم الورق يعني كل احنا عملناه يلا هيطلع لايف.
Learner B3: ، بالضبط.
Learner B1: إيه بس الأخيرة مش هيزيد اسبوع تاني يعني.
Learner B3: أحسن ولا كان أحسن حابين نزيد أكتر.
Learner B1: أنا ما أعرفش أنا معرفش هم هيجيدوا لا بس من التصفية الموعودة معنى كده النداء معرفش بقى هو حيجوده من عندهم ويعملوا حاجة تاني ولا.
Learner B3: هو قال إن هو سبينت فورس ذي فاينل ويك يعني وابعت لي كده أحمد منصور.
Learner B1: بدي أيه ولا ابعتلك هناك فرق أنا ما أعتمد.
Learner B3: عارفة صراحة.
Learner B4: هو ما فيش حد موديل.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B4: كله طفل.
Learner B1: هم لسا هم اصلا لسه ما عرفوا.
Learner B3: سألت هو أنا مش عارفة تقريبا مش عارفة سارة نفسها اللي ردت علي أو لأ بس تقريبا قالتلي انها غرب بس ده قبل ما المنتر يقول لنا إن هو.
Learner B4: والله أنا مسافر يوم خمستاشر.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B4: عايزين يعملوها بعد ما عنديش مشكلة عايزين يأجروها خالص ماعنديش.
Learner B3: حتعدي كم يوم يعني ولا قصدك حتعدي فترة طويلة.
Learner B4: والله مش عارفة هي بيزنس تريب فمش عارفة الدنيا تمشي الزاي فيها.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B4: الشحن الجوف.
Learner B3: تروحي تيجي بالسلامة لأ إن شاء الله يبقى 13 أبلي.
Learner B1: وأنا أتمنى أكون.
Learner B3: بكرة إنتو تمام يا جماعة هندخل مع محمد حاتم ميتينغ صح؟
Learner B4: أنا ما عنديش مشكلة في أي حاجة يلا كان عشان إيه معلش يا مريم.
Learner B1: مفيدة.
Learner B3: بصي هو أنا كنت يعني كنت كلمتوا، كنت سألتوا على كم حاجة
Learner B3: بتبعت برضه أنا عامة حاسة هلب فلوي يعني أنا حساها هلب؟ فل
Learner B3: بس هو مفروض بعث؟ إن أنا كنت عايزة فيدباك ففي كونفورميشن وكده مفروض فأنا مش عارفة في الآخر حيتبعت إديتها دي ولا لأ
Learner B3: فبسألنا ممكن ندخل ميتينغ ويجاوب على الأسئلة وكدا فا بس.
Learner B4: ماشي يلا مين هذا الغشوش.
Learner B3: كل 1 ب 1,000.
Learner B4: شكرا.
Learner B3: أو لو حد عمل بروتتي تايب حابب مثلا يسأل على حاجة أو كده نجمع الأسئلة يعني.
Learner B7: يعني.
Learner B4: إمم.
Learner B7: نعمله على الانترنت بس من جهة ال مينتيرز ولا السكويه.
Learner B3: لا، لا، هي دي حاجة زيادة هو فكرة نوع كان بيقول إن إحنا أي حاجة أو أي نطلعها نسأل سبرينس نعرف ديتيلز أكتر نعرف إزاي عشان نعرف ندي فلوسي يعني كويسة وكده
Learner B3: في معناه فبس محمد حاتم بيشتغل هناك حجزت سوفتوير تقريبا.
Learner B4: يسويف.
Learner B4: وإن جنيف.
Learner B3: أنا حتى برضه هقولك على حاجة أنا بفكر برضه أسأل تيم سوفت وير هي أبليكيبل ولا لأ على أي مدى وكده وهشرح الموضوع ده أكثر في ممكن تاخده قد وكده يعني.
Learner B4: لا، حقيقة. لا حقيقة عارفة حاجة تزوج ولا لا برضه نحبس سيكوريتي عشان خاطرش عملت حاجة فازة في الآخر ما.
Learner B3: هو ما إنت كان عنده حق يعني ممكن أديشن عبقري تحفة بس هو أصلا صعب يتنفذ يعملوا.
Learner B4: إمم ماشي زي الفل احنا محدش برضو طبعا في التصفيات صح.
Learner B3: أنا بدأت على خفيف.
Learner B4: وإلا.
Learner B1: التوستعمل يعني هنجهز إن إحنا نبقى يعني هنعمل فرنش اللي هو تيستنغ يعني.
Learner B4: هنعمل و تيستينج وحنعمل وحنعمل تاني ثانية وحدة.
Learner B1: ماكريس.
Learner B4: ده طبيعي إن إحنا نعمل والتشيكليست.
Learner B1: سوتشيك تيست اللي هو.
Learner B4: هو.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B4: وبرجنتين.
Learner B1: عندي في ماشي.
Learner B4: وهنعمل بريزنتيشن ذي ليفر أكوهنسف بريزنتيشن
Learner B4: أوكي.
Learner B1: لا حول ولا قوة إلا بالله.
Learner B4: طفافة.
Learner B4: لا، لا، لا، لا، لا بس حلو كمان حلو.
Learner B7: أنا سامع طيب شغل يعني طالما بقى ماركتينغ بقى وحاجات برا كده حاسة إن الموضوع بقى محتاج شغل بجد
Learner B7: يعني حصل اللي فات كلو كان كلو في دلوقتي محتاج ان هو يكون شغل حقيقي.
Learner B1: عندي سؤال معلش هو السؤال ده مش مش وقته أو مش وقت قوي ليه علاقة بالموضوع معلش أنا هقاطعك ما قاطعتك. أنا آسف، بس هو فكرة كل 1 فينا عملت بطريقته
Learner B1: اللي هو دي بقى أهم شي
Learner B7: بنعرف من المهندس حيتم أو أحمد حاتم بكرا وخلاص.
Learner B4: محمد حاتم وممكن أو يوم الخميس ونسأل مرزوق أو خليني أبعث لمرزوق لو انتو حابين اعرف.
Learner B1: حيقولكم إنتو فريتر واتفقوا مع بعض حتعرضوا كلامكم ازاي
Learner B1: يعني آخر 1 فينا هو يمشي او حناخد بقى حتة من الشرق او الغرب.
Learner B3: ثانية. مش كل 1 عنده فيديو أصلا.
Learner B1: ما اعتقدش هم الجروب ازاي.
Learner B3: لا.
Learner B7: استرال.
Learner B3: ده مفروض.
Learner B7: وكان كمان في في توبر فورمانس بحددوا منه كمان أظن هيكون.
Learner B3: هو في تيمز في تيمز فعلا غروب بس تقريبا بي ام عندنا مش غروب هيبقى.
Learner B4: تحبوا أسأله كمان عايزو.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B4: ميرسي يلا بينا أي حد يشوف اي حاجة الاسبوع ده.
Learner B1: آخر شيء.
Learner B4: كبير إمم.
Learner B1: دي كويسة.
Learner B4: يوم.
Learner B1: إنت إنت عليكي والله في من بين.
Learner B4: مبال علي بطولتي عادل.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B4: بتقولش عادل بينه علي.
Learner B1: خالص ده إنتي عاملة دماغ إلا ربنا جميل.
Learner B4: لا.
Learner B1: يلا ربنا معك يا رب خير خير عنك.
Learner B4: أكيد لأ هم يعني يعني هم طارجتيلي الأسبوع يعني حاجة جميلة جدا هي جميلة جدا. أنا فخورة.
Learner B1: شغل
Learner B4: هو بس الشغل الكبير شادد و إمم.
Learner B7: عايزة أسأل على حاجة من التاسك في حاجة لها علاقة بالماركتينغ وكده، وإننا خلاص بقى أتوقع الدي تي ام دا أنا قررت قبل كده له علاقة بالمبيعات
Learner B7: صح.
Learner B4: يلا.
Learner B1: مش ما.
Learner B4: إذ.
Learner B7: صح.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B4: هو الجوتو مارك ثينج استراتيجي يعني يعني ببساطة شديدة أنا حقتم السوق إزاي الإستراتيجية اللي حعملها عشان أنزل أعمل هيك في السوق.
Learner B7: طيب سؤال بس دلوقتي علاقة إن أنا يعني علاقة إنه أنا دلوقتي
Learner B7: هعمل استراتيجية أنزل بيها للسوق وأنا أصلا شغالة على حاجة ليها علاقة بأن أنا بحسب دلوقتي ألريدي أنا بحسن
Learner B7: يعني هنزل بقى السوق في دلوقتي يعني فهمتني.
Learner B4: حدا يرد ولا ممكن أردني.
Learner B1: محاولة ربط ممكن تردي.
Learner B4: إنت ممكن تعتبريها أو إزاي الجديدة أو جلادي الجديدة يعني إعتبري إن هو عمله مثلا سبرينت اللي فات أو دي
Learner B4: شوية بصيص يعني ممكن تكون بس هم ما حطوش نفسهم في بوسيشنج معين في الماركت
Learner B4: فإنت بعد التحسينات ده الحاجة اللي حتخليكي تقولي أنا هنزل أعمل تسويق ليا بالتدريب اللي أنا بقدمه ده بالشكل الفلاني.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B1: أرفب.
Learner B4: في.
Learner B1: إيه رأي كل منتج بيطلع فيديو بحكاية وكل حاجة صح.
Learner B7: أيوه.
Learner B1: هو هي هي اللي إنت عملتيها ده بلبن هذه حاجات.
Learner B7: هو باللبن فيها.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B7: هو بلبن فعلا يعني.
Learner B1: بالزبط.
Learner B3: هو جماعته. تجربوا الإيمي تيستينج فعلا ولا بس حتكتبوا كونسبت.
Learner B1: أنا مش سامع.
Learner B3: هل جربوا تبعته يعني بريجنس جربوا ولا بس تكتبوا كنسبت وفكر وكده يعني.
Learner B4: أنا ناوية إن أنا أعمله بس على حسب أنا اللي حطلعه أعمل إزاي.
Learner B1: أنا ملاحظات صحية ازاي يعني.
Learner B7: سؤال يا جماعة هو مش المفروض برضو نحن شغالين على حاجة تانية لها علاقة بأن إحنا نعمل على
Learner B7: على الناس وكده ونعمل تلفزيز ونشوف تحسينات يعني أظن الجانب ده لسه. شغال.
Learner B4: يس الغاندلس.
Learner B3: موضوع فعلا.
Learner B7: أحس إن إحنا في حصتين مختلفين خالص.
Learner B3: قصدك
Learner B7: حصل طاس يركز على حاجة واللي إحنا مطلوب مننا طلب مننا مبارح بقى حاجة تانية.
Learner B3: بصي أنا يعني أنا شايفة ده اللي أنا شايفه يعني إن كده دي حاجة أساسية إن إحنا نعمل مش عارفة إي يعني بحس في كل سبينت لازم يبقى مبني على والماكت برضه دي حاجة أساسية فاهمة
Learner B3: أنا كمان.
Learner B7: مقدمة.
Learner B3: دي. أه قولي.
Learner B7: أيوة بس إحنا خلاص رايحين نعمل استراتيجية ماركتينغ مش عارف كذا عشان خاطر
Learner B7: نبي الحاجة اللي احنا يعني نزبط بقى الحاجة اللي احنا خلاص ألريدي عملناها فإزاي لسه حنبدأ نفكر في تحسينات حاجة كده بصراحة يعني الحتة دي.
Learner B3: أنا حاسة إن هو إحنا ممكن نطبق ده على يعني تطوير أو في الآخر يعتبر أصلا جديدة لسه
Learner B3: فأنا أنا هشوفها كده أنا ما أعرفش ممكن تسألي المانتي بس أنا هشوفها كده يعني فاهمة.
Learner B7: يعني أنا ممكن أشوف مثلا هل أشوفها إن أنا أعتبر نفسي إن أنا إشتغلت تحسين الموضوع كله فدي الوقت أنا ببيع الكورس نفسه أو تاني
Learner B7: بعد تحصينات اللي اتعملت.
Learner B3: يعني أنا حاسة يعني أيمن نحنا يعني إيه التحسين وإزاي هتنزلي يعني كأنك هتنزلي الموضوع ده بالتحسينات بتاعته فاهمة إزاي حتطوري.
Learner B7: هو لازم كنا نحضر الجام اذا كلنا نحضر.
Learner B3: بس أنا مش متأكدة بس إنت مش حابة تحضريه.
Learner B7: جار.
Learner B3: بس إنت ممكن تسألي.
Learner B7: هو لو حاجة عبارة عن بريزنتيشن وبنعمل فيها كذا فأنا حاسة إن
Learner B7: لأ ما عنديش حاجة أطلع بيها بصراحة
Learner B7: مبارح بعد ما اتفرجت على على ريكورد بتاع ميتينغ أصلا. كنت عمال أدخل وأخرج بسبب كويسة بس بعد ما اتفرجت عليه هو ريكورد حسيت إن أنا كويس إن أنا يعني ما دخلتش قوي يعني حسيت إن هو في اختلاف كبير جدا بين بتاعك والطاسك بتاع عادل
Learner B7: حضرتك كان شاور حاجة مختلفة يعني الروان كانوا شاغلين عن نفس الحاجة
Learner B7: بس عايز كل 1 في حتة.
Learner B3: بصي حقولك على حاجة أولا أحس إن إنت تكوني تايهة أو كده دي حاجة طبيعية يعني أنا عن نفسي أنا كتير بحس. إنها تائهة إن أنا أول مرة أصلا أدخل مجال فأنا فهماكي قوي ثاني حاجة ما حاولي تشوفي الموضوع بيلعب على أكتر اللي هو شوفي إنت هتاخدي هتفهمي إيه مش لازم بحذافير رول بالضبط
Learner B3: كل 1 عملها بمنطقة كريتيف أكتر فاهمة فا
Learner B3: يعني فاهمة قصدي بحاول أقولك يعني حلو إنك تفهمي التاسكت وكده بس ده حصل ده فكرة أصلا إن كل 1 يتعلم لوحده ويبدع في التاسس،
Learner B3: فما تخليهاش حاجة زي ضيعك يعني فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B7: أنا فاهمة بس حتة إن إحنا نكون شغالين على حتة إن إحنا بنحسن أصلا كإكسبيرينس أصلا وكنتايج
Learner B7: دي حاجة أنا شايفها بالنسبة لي ممكن تكون إنتو مش شايفينها يعني ممكن تكونوا إنتو فاهمينها من بدري بس بالنسبة لي أنا فهمتها متأخر أوي إن إحنا أصلا قاعدين شغالين على تحسينات
Learner B7: والمفروض كل 1 فينا يسمع فيدباك من غيره ونبدأ نجيب على أساس الموضوع. ده أنا لو كنت ملتزمة بالتاسكت بس والمكتوب فيها. بس ويعني ولأن دائما لما كنا بنطلب داتا كمان في بداية
Learner B7: كنا بنعملها في البداية خالص كان دائما الكلام نعمله على ناس من برا ناس على بلاد فورمز ثانية. فالموضوع ما كانش متعلق بس هنا
Learner B7: فحاسة إن مؤخرا بدأت أدرك إن مفروض نطلع بحاجة تحسن لكن التاسكات دي كانت حاجة هي اللي أنا ملتزمة بعمل بداية ومكانش وضعها غير كده
Learner B7: فحسنا في ده حيكون محتاج شغل عالموضوع. ده من البداية،
Learner B7: فأنا شايفة نفسي متأخرة بالنسبة لنفسي بصراحة يعني ممكن تكونوا إنتو فاهمين الموضوع ده من بدري ولاقطينه
Learner B7: بس أنا بالنسبة لنفسي حاسة قاعدة متأخرة يعني حاسة أشتغل عليه من أول أصلا.
Learner B3: بصي أنا فهماكي بس هو صدقيني يعني كل 1 عنده حتة أنا أصلا لما كنت داخلة عايزة أقولك دي كنت فاكرة سبنت الفيديوهات اللي على الويب سايت هيدي فأنا بتكلم في حاجة ثانية، خالص وأنا بقيت معاكم في الجروب عشان أنا أصلا يعني عملت كاسك حاجة ثانية بالصدفة
Learner B3: والله مش لوحدك اللي جايها أنا عملت بالصدفة لما دخلت ال ميتينغ اللي كان حاطين فيدباك. أنا بس إستغليت اللي أنا معايا ده عشان كان عندي نفس البوينت من أول يعني من أول قلت خلاص أنا حاخدها فرصة إن أنا أعمل على حجر
Learner B3: بس إنت لو حاسة إن إنت مش جاهزة أو حاجة أو حابة إن إنتي تجهزي بريزنتيشن وقت اكتر ممكن تطلبي.
Learner B4: بس.
Learner B3: حاسة بصراحة إن إنت لو حاولتي تركزي أو تحاولي تعملي مش لازم حتى يبقى حاجة
Learner B3: ده حيبقى مفيد ليكي لأن ويلايف إنت لما تنزلي أوقات حيبقى مطلوب منك حاجات إنت مش ده منها. تبقى جاهزة.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B3: هذا تشالينج هيفيدك أنت.
Learner B3: بس جولي ريحك يعني.
Learner B7: يعني نشوف كده لما نشوف تفاصيل الدماء تكون عاملة زي.
Learner B3: خلاص إن شاء الله.
Learner B4: مريم. انت قلت كلام زي الفولت.
Learner B3: الله يخليكي.
Learner B4: ما فيش
Learner B4: يا زينب إحنا كلنا كلنا في عندنا حتة فيها
Learner B4: التاسست مبارح كل 1 تكلم في حتة أنا لو شفت التاسكي بتاعي حتقلي ملش علاقة خالص بقى لما مريم ولا بعادل أنا بحس إن أنا ماسكة حتة لوحدي كده وعايشة هناك مع نفسي هو كل 1
Learner B4: كان بيحاول يشوف المشكلة فين من وجهة نظره هو وإيه اللي شايف لو حسنه. حيفرق
Learner B4: فهي من ضمن المميزات ممكن تكون ليها عبر وتوابس من دون ميزات. إن أنا
Learner B4: أشوف غيري بيفكر إزاي، أنا أتذكر إن أنا في عيد الفوتوستا معينة قلت له عايز أنا عايزة أشوفك إزاي بعد ما أنا قدمت وهو خلصنا اللي فات ليه
Learner B4: الجواب إزاي أشوف دماغ ثانية غير دماغي أنا
Learner B4: شوف طريقة تفكيري طريقة تفكيري قوي
Learner B4: فاهمة قصدي فهي دي النقطة إن أنا بشوف زوايا كتير طريقة تفكيرهم مختلفة
Learner B4: فده يخليني أنا لما أتحط في مواقف تانية يبقى عندي دماغي وعندي سمعت فكرة من عادل قالي 1 2 3
Learner B4: فدي فكرة لا البريزنتيشن أو ما تقدري تعملي الدي موديل إعمليه مش لأي حاجة غير إن إنتي كسرتي عندك حاجز
Learner B4: و بتاخدوا ثقة وطبيعي أنت جزء من برودكت
Learner B4: ده شغلك تبيتيها و حتتعاملي مع ناس كتيرة قوي وال سيكوردرز مختلفين وكل 1 منهم دماغ مسوحي.
Learner B3: بصراحة أتفق قوي مع ندى يعني فعلا عندها حق قوي و أنا فعلا برضه أنا لما شفت عامة التاسك بتاع عادل امبارح وكان في 1 معانا كده برضه زيادة حسيت برضه إن هو عادي التاسك بتاعتي برضه مختلفة
Learner B3: فده شعور طبيعي بس مفروض بدل ما نحس حاجة كده لأ نحس إن إحنا نأخذ أفكار من بعض نبقى، أكتر فأنت عادي. اسمعي ريكوردينغ شوفي مثلا ممكن تاخذي من كل حد مثلا يفتحلك إيه يخليكي إنتي كريتيف فاهمة مش إن هو كأن لا أنا مختلفة عنهم لأ لو فكرنا كده كلنا مختلفين عن بعض
Learner B3: بس إحنا هنا عشان نشجع بعض مش إن إحنا نحس كده فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B7: ايوا تمام جدا. شكرا.
Learner B3: ولو عايزة أي حاجة على فكرة عادي إحنا ممكن معاكي يعني ممكن عادي تشهري مثلا.
Learner B4: بالظبط معاكيشن عايز.
Learner B1: اعملي بريزنتيشن الدنيا حتى لو كلمة على موضوع مختلف
Learner B1: عارفة يعني حاجة تانية مش عارف كيف حتقولي إيه
Learner B4: الجملة. سمعتها في حياتي عادي.
Learner B1: بتقول لي.
Learner B3: لا.
Learner B4: بحياتي.
Learner B1: لا، مش سامعك.
Learner B4: أحلى جملة سمعتها في حياتي.
Learner B1: والله يعني عارفة يعني لو دخلتي عليه وأنا آسف والله لو بتغني الصحي ده عارفة عادي ما فيش مشكلة إنت بقى ما بالك حتقولي حاجة إنت فعلا عملتيها وطبقتيها واعترضتي عليها حتهنجي عادي هنجي ما إحنا كلنا منهج اللي قدامك نفسه ده لو
Learner B1: قدام أي حد يهنك برضه عادي.
Learner B3: بالظبط.
Learner B4: أنا أنا مع عادل جدا متصادمة في حياتي كتير، وخصوصا في الشغل اللي قدامك منتش عارف إنت حتقول فاللي أنا بقوله هو ده.
Learner B1: بالضبط.
Learner B4: هو ده.
Learner B1: بالزبط. أنت هتقولي حاجات إنت فعلا عملتيها يعني إنت مش حتجيبي حاجات من برا لأ إنت إشتغلني على الطاسكي دي والنقطة دي كانت مش كويسة فيها وإنتي حتقولي حاجة اللي عملتيها فخلاص اللي قدامك مش هيبقى عارف إنت حتقولي إيه بالتفصيل لا عادي خشي وحكي
Learner B1: ودي مش عارفة ودي لسه قدامنا إن شاء الله في المستقبل القريب.
Learner B3: بالزبط وبعدين. هي بجد هنا الثقة بتفرق عارفة لو إنت بجد يعني عندك مثلا قليلة بس تكلمت بثقة كده قوي بجد والله بتفرق 1,000,000 في المية مش متخيلة.
Learner B7: ما بعرف أمثل عادي بس بجد ممكن إن أنا دي القليلة دي بجد تبان
Learner B7: كلام مكسر كلام متلذق كده فواضح ان هو هدأ بأي حد يجرب بجد بيكتشف الهد يعني.
Learner B3: لا بصي هو في فرق لأ هو مش حوار. إن أنت تبقي واثقة إن إنت تمثلي. لا أنت عاملة بروجكت ده وإنت واثقة من شغلك ودي خلاص أنا عملت اللي علي فده فأنا هشرح أنا وصلت لإيه. وفهمت حاجة ولو في حاجة مش فهماها عادي أنا عامة في حاجة لسه مش فاهمة أوي بقول أنا لسه. في بروسيس لسه شغالة على ده مش آخر الدنيا في الآخر أنت لسه في الجامعة ولسه تتعلمي وإحنا حتى وإحنا متخرجين لسه نتعلم كل يوم
Learner B3: التعميم عمره ما يخلص يعني فاهمة.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B3: نفسها أصلا يعني فيها حاجات كثيرة قوي إحنا ما نسجلش إنها تبقى أحسن فهم لو الحاجة بيرفت المليون في المية ما كناش نبقى شغالين عليها يعني
Learner B3: أو ممكن نبقى شغالين عليها بس يعني السر إحنا عندنا حلو قوي فاهمة قصدي
Learner B3: فزي ما عادة بيقول فوكيت يعني.
Learner B1: لنفسك أنت يعني أي فيدباك من أي حاجة يعني والله رأيي أي حد ولا أي حاجة إنت إعملي ده اللي هو إغلطي إنتي عادي.
Learner B7: فرنج.
Learner B1: إحنا.
Learner B7: ما حد قال لي حاجة ولا هم اللي قالولي.
Learner B1: بالظبط شاطرة اللي هتقولي كل حاجة إحنا نعتمد عليك.
Learner B7: إن شاء الله.
Learner B1: مع السلامة.
Learner B4: فحد عايز يقول حاجة ولا نروح للعطاس.
Learner B3: عسى نبدأ.
Learner B1: ربنا كده.
Learner B1: ربنا يخليك فين يلا.
Learner B4: الله يخليك يا علي.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B4: مرزولة وردها أي حد يبعتلي طبعا أي وقت.
Learner B1: ثوم أقفل القشر. أقفل.
Learner B4: كيف يلا.
Learner B1: اضحك علي.
Learner B4: يا ريت حكاية.
Learner B1: ما خلتك.
Learner B4: مساء الخير.
Learner B1: هذا.
Learner B3: يبا يا جماعة.
Learner B1: ما.